what up reject Nation we are here today
to watch from our friend poor heavy
spoilers
classic The Last of Us episode 8 Easter
eggs and breakdown and you know there's
some goodies I'm looking forward to the
thoughts that he has on this one joined
of course by Jew number one at the
channel there's Roxy and Michael hey
you're number one manishma
what don't speak the devil's tongue in
my household acor 7-Eleven
thanks buddy thank you for that
introduction I'm uh I might be a little
bit sad on this episode I still haven't
gotten over kallus from uh this last
episode but um we'll see how I do let's
we'll see
that's uh that's the horse I know
there's always good reaction energy
right here anyway guys uh leave a like
that would be very much appreciated I
love when you leave a like hey hey guess
what guys
[Music]
the other ones in the washer right now
the one you should get from
shopzeredition.com but you know what
keeps me afloat the fuel as I call them
God fuel that's what the G stands for in
G fuel I'm assuming you use special
promo code reject Nation Link in the
description box get yourself some G fuel
today over there what do you see over
there Richard
that's a lot of God fuel that's a lot of
God fuel that's been drank for a lot of
late night editing sessions and boy does
it keep this channel afloat let's get to
it
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down episode 8 of The Last of
Us this is the one I've been waiting for
and David in the games one of the most
memorable characters that you come
across when playing David voiced by
Nolan North he started off as an
apparent Ally but as you begin to learn
more about him you start to see his more
Sinister side no blood as quick as in
the infected were terrifying I think one
of the scariest things for me was
playing as Ellie and moving about the
restaurant as he walks through a
terrifying machete that level in the
game it's terrifying so hard for me to
figure out how to beat this and I'm like
I don't get it I can kill bloaters and
all these other people but this one dude
is taking me forever to be oh yeah
because if you step on the glass or you
have to listen to him and then sometimes
the listen mode doesn't isn't it very
accurate it's just no it's a terrifying
love but I like it because it makes you
not feel Invincible which most of the
game depending on what difficulty level
you are playing on most of the game can
you can feel like an invincible
character so I actually liked in that
moment it's bogged down to no you're not
invincible like you can die and I died
several times on that part I play on
very easy with cheat codes by the way
it's still hard normally Boss characters
and games are gigantic monsters or
highly scaled characters there was just
something so unnerving about a creepy 50
year old cannibal walking around looking
for you now as is with all Last of Us
episodes the fact that we aren't playing
the game means that they can show things
from the perspective of others in the
PlayStation counterpart you are locked
to the POV of Joel and Ali Raz here we
can see more of David's backstory that's
how we begin as well and we open by
looking over his town which is called
Silver Lake in both the shown game we
discover David has taken and upon
himself to become a holy man and over
the top of this we hear him narrating
Revelation 21. his opening line
discusses the new Heaven and new earth
and this very much reflects the new
world that they've found themselves in
the midst of the verses in this chapter
talk about how there'll be no need for a
physical temple in this new world
because God's presence will be
everywhere the Jewish that's from the
Bible I was actually thinking my I'm
gonna get a joke right here it's not a
joke that is from the Bible I'm talking
about the real God
okay I'll have to read it sometime we
then jumped to see him hitched up in
Todd's Steakhouse to watch him
delivering a sermon Todd's restaurant
was what it was called in the game and
it's been transformed into a makeshift
church we see how people have tried to
find reason in what's happened to the
world and you can totally understand why
someone turned to religion I didn't want
to spoil this episode all the way back
in the first entry but it's even
possible that Mrs Adler could have
foreshadowed people going like this
well that's true every day isn't it
people out there need to get right with
Jesus now religion Beyond things ah yes
also acts as a way to explain things for
example thousands of years ago people
didn't understand how the world was
formed but religions gave these answers
whilst also outlining the best ways to
live thus people flock towards them
because science hadn't given
Alternatives I'm trying to explain this
as best as possible as I can without
offending people what I'm trying to say
is that in this once more stripped back
world you can see why people would end
up becoming religious a lot of people
don't have the scientific tools to
answer things and those preachers could
provide the answers and compared to
those that feel lost yeah no it makes a
lot of sense to me that people would
become spiritual in a sense like this
because of the fact that when you're
feeling so hopeless sometimes you will
look to something to find that sense of
hope and I'm not saying that if you are
religious all jokes aside with your
Judaism I would understand someone
wanting to I could see both sides of the
coin here so I'm going there's clearly
no God look at the world we live in or
no there has to be a caucus there has to
be something good after all this has
passed right yeah but I also like the
way David explained in the episode I
mean was done methodically and very
Sinister the way he talked about how he
didn't believe in God it wasn't until
you know the outbreak and and the
quarter steps uh brain infection started
that now he started believing and it was
it's just a very more Sinister take on
it and I actually thought it was really
executed really oh well so I I liked his
uh explanation it was kind of messed up
the way he explained it but I I thought
it like worked well for the character a
Revelations is about the end of the
world and this it's easy to see why so
many people attend to this and David
after the world had ended it hasn't been
all sunshine and rainbows though and
Judah longhold Winters David has had to
resort to cannibalism in order to keep
people alive you see a sign hanging up
saying when we are in need he shall
provide and this is playing on
Philippians 4 19 which states God will
provide for people I knew it said in the
reaction I think that was a Philippians
quote because there's some quotes I knew
because I always thought it said
Philippines when I was growing up and
for some reason that's stood out to me
it's not exactly the same thing but I
was like I think it's a Philippines
quote Pinoy Pride even though it's not
Pinoy but Pinoy Pride his sign is also
pulled over to the game and when Ellie
fights David in a restaurant you see the
sign hanging up at the back of the room
oh he's had to cross the line in order
to provide but David's hiddenness from
the people whereas in the game I always
kind of got the impression that the town
smoke were aware yeah now you might be
wondering why they don't just move
somewhere warm well the fact is that
people here feel safe and they very much
control our society they're not
oppressed by Federer and the in fact it
also tended to stick to warmer areas
though you didn't counter some in the
snow when you first met David the second
game showed the exposure to the elements
left them completely Frozen you also
discovered that every time they bunker
Dan the writers eventually showed up and
thus they had to find somewhere that
wasn't too appealing to others so Salt
Lake is probably the best place to be
though the cruel Winters have meant that
food becomes scarce now interesting
little tidbit for you mate did you know
that Viking things called it Iceland
because it would put Invaders off from
going there they called Greenland that
because it was covered in ice and thus
when Invaders arrived there they'd be
like sake anyway he goes
after pain God will make it so there's
no more sorrow we learn this girl has
just lost her father and that they want
to bury him but the ground is too cold
David calls himself a father and it's
very much a perverted version of the dad
and daughter relationship that Joel has
with Ellie where as Joel will do
anything to protect Ellie David smacks
her in front of people and they're very
much surrogate fathers at opposite ends
of the scale anyway I'm getting the word
Notch yes David is one of them and I
think that's what made the character in
the game so creepy I think this is
obviously commenting on controversies
surrounding the church and gonna be
difficult not to offend people but it's
definitely an important thing to address
the entire holy man thing with David is
something I wasn't present in the game
and I think it adds a whole new
dimension to him when he's This creepy
religious figure that eats people and
prays on children at this point we get a
quick cut of his right hand man James
and in case you don't recognize him
that's Troy Baker who he actually played
Joe in the game and beggar gave his
seminal performance I think actually
helped out with a lot of the success of
the last of us he's a very beloved voice
actor he's played lots of different
iconic characters and I have to say that
I think he completely knocked it out the
park the funny thing is seeing Troy
Baker here it made me go could have
played like I love what Pedro Pascal's
doing but he could have played the
live-action version of Joel like he
looks enough like if they want to do a
little bit more of an accurate fiction
yeah I mean it will be extremely
accurate for this try Baker but he looks
enough like the game counterpart and
what they did with the model of Joel I
agree with you and before Pedro Pascal
was cast and obviously I never thought
they would actually cast Troy Baker I
always had in my head I I thought Josh
Brolin could do an interesting job as uh
as Joel but I mean because I'd only been
exposed to listening to Troy Baker in
video games from Batman Arkham Origins
as the Joker to obviously The Last of Us
Parts one and two and many others he's
got extreme range when it comes to
acting but seeing him actually in live
action what he was able to do in this
episode is James I'm like holy crap he's
actually a good live-action actor too
like I definitely could have seen him as
Joel but having said that I freaking
loved Pedro Pascal he's so damn good
it's so damn good so far on the show
we've had Marlene's voice actor playing
her in the series Tommy's popped up as
Perry now Baker is playing Ashley
Johnson next left is Ellie's Ashley
Johnson so I can imagine that she'll be
popping up next for the finale the raw
rumors about who she could be playing
let's explain them
Baker actually looks a lot like Childers
in the game and I as much as I love
Pedro I wouldn't have minded him playing
him in a live action too look I'm not
trying to offend people again and
outside we hear how dire of a situation
they're in when it comes to rations in
the game we never saw this side of
things and after Joel fell off his horse
at the University he then cut to Ali
hunting and whilst you were doing this
he noticed the bark that he then shot an
arrow in this didn't kill it unless he
tracked it through the environment
trying to take it out for food it fled
to an abandoned Factory which is when
you found it dead now at this point
James and David step forward now here we
see the other side of it with James and
David talking about how some their
spotters saw a deer the other day you
see how their paths now cross from both
sides and also explore the doubt within
James he's clearly wrestling with the
fact that they're crossing the line in
order to keep going and adds a lot of
complexity to the character that wasn't
originally there absolutely it was
pretty much just an NPC with a couple of
lines
out so we get much more of his thoughts
I thought what they did with James
vastly improved upon a character that
just felt like a nothing character in
the in the actual video game and it adds
more to the real world qualities of
having a cult-like leader here because
you got to have at least someone who is
in this realm of feeling doubtful of of
the path that they're on and it helps
just humanize and flesh out the entire
experience of this cult that has
essentially formed here so I thought
like what they did with Troy Baker never
distracted from the main storyline and
it didn't feel like it needed to become
more fleshed out or more of a focus it
was just enough to enhance the
experience in the video game again there
was that one moment where he asked James
to go get you know the penicillin and
the syringe for Ellie and you could see
like the doubt like well I don't know
like I'm not gonna go get it so they
touched a little bit upon him but it was
expanded upon so much more in this
episode he was a lot more of a
three-dimensional character here and I
actually like that because position that
they put him in because again if you
hadn't played the game you're just the
general going audience and you didn't
know what was going to happen later on
in the episode which obviously if you
played the game you know but I like that
it kind of created a rift between them
and like oh my God I I kept thinking in
my head okay I know what happens but it
really feels like David at any second
could shoot him or he could shoot David
if I didn't know it was already gonna
happen I thought they did a great job of
just adding that that layer to it
between the two characters and this
cannibalism in the snow could be a
reference to the Donna party who are a
group of American Pioneers who migrated
to California from the Midwest they got
stuck in a snowy mountain range for a
while and had to resort to cannibalism
like what we see yeah James is starting
to doubt whether this is God's way and
it's possible he knows about the other
stuff too in the game when Joe ambushes
the town you overhearsome saying that
David's leadership should be put to a
vote again so this sentiment was clearly
felt among some of the other inhabitants
in the game I don't remember that one I
don't know yeah but you did hear a woman
saying that they were moving the
children to a shelter now in the game
James the children okay evidently waited
for him which is when they were both
sworn by infected you had to make your
way that's my favorite scene in the show
I made your final stand against some
Runners clickers in a blowder in the
game you had no idea what was up with
David at this point and it allowed you
to build some camaraderie with him so
absolutely no he'd forward lots of
hunters the the people that you'd met in
cut scenes had ended up becoming your
allies this was the case with Marlene
Henry and Sam and of course Joel's
brother Tommy it sort of lured you into
this false sense of security with him
and when listening to the kind of funny
podcast a couple of weeks ago it did
bring up a point that stuck with me
since then they said that Kathleen might
have even heard that David reveal a bear
because we'd already experienced an evil
leader figure though I don't know if
that's fully the case I do think having
two characters like this in the show
hurt the fact that David was someone you
came across who was worse than the
infected you don't really trust him from
the Star whereas in the game you kind of
did yeah and I kind of feel and missed
that gut Punchy bear let me know below
if it caught you off God I'm weirdly not
that bothered by it it's weird how they
like kind of changed they added this
Kathleen character and then they change
parts of the thing with David and the
person who died in their camp that feel
like they're in support and slash setup
or what's to come in The Last of Us Part
Two I mean I thought David was
suspicious in in the game right away
then that fight scene is more than just
a fight scene it it builds a trust it
makes that speech later on make more
sense for when David is trying to court
her to be his Queen first of all for
people saying hey stop comparing into
the game it's it's called the last just
to say something really quick about that
it's much more challenging to for for
some people sometimes it happens to me
with the show to not compare it to the
game because of the fact that it's not
like doing a book where a book is just a
narrated text whereas here there's so
many visual medium parallels that are
adapting it that you're you're more
likely to go wow and in the game they
look like human beings too so you're
more likely to compare there's so much
storytelling that goes on in this action
sequence like again you get that false
sense of oh David might actually be a
friendly he had that gun in his and
again this is the the game I'm talking
about but he had that gun the entire
time and he gave Ellie his rifle he
could have shot her at any time that he
wanted to but he didn't it just adds so
much more layers to it that was actually
one of the very rare times in this show
where something was cut out that that
personally bothered me sorry to you
people that in the don't compare camp
now back with Ali we see she now says
Joe the surroundings here are identical
to the game with him being on a dirty
mattress with a couple of blankets to
keep him warm we had a shot similar to
the game where she examines his wound
and this is something she did Upon
returning from David seeing how little
food they have left I did go back and
forth over what the intention of this
scene was she does hold a snap of it for
a second and I even thought that she
might be wondering whether it's worth
giving it to him due to him being so
close to that store I don't think that's
what was intended and I'm sure that the
HBO podcast will probably clear this up
we do these videos before that's
released so I don't really get to hear
things people yeah some people genuinely
think are watching our long episode and
listen to a 40-minute podcast and then
make a 30 to 40 minute video and release
it this if only you could if only you
just could we've been using time travel
dude
out
now but like I said I don't think that's
the intention and Nelly decides to mount
up and go hunting yeah she comes across
a rabbit like in the game and I have to
play this clip again sorry that's the
cutest [__] thing I've ever seen in
my entire life
look I'm a vegetarian yet but still it's
a good reaction unlike the PlayStation
counterpart Ellie's pretty useless or as
she was taking out animals with ease and
that we see here how she's really
struggling well she's struggling in the
game there's a three month time Jump or
something right yeah so she has time to
like develop her skills yeah yeah not
really a time Jump battle maybe a couple
days right yeah sometimes you never know
what these shows are like no there was
like a three-month time yeah and also
too I forgot to mention too in that
scene that they cut out the that amazing
action sequence David specifically said
to Ellie it's a four mile hike now I
don't know if that was he was just lying
that it was four miles so we're gonna be
here a while and then they move the deer
in but I don't know how long the passage
of time was in that scene but it was a
pretty quick conversation where he
reveals what happens and then James is
immediately back so if that really again
I know this is nitpicking but if it
really was four miles because you cut
that action sequence now you put
yourself in a little hole there and you
got Dum Dum Dums like me on the Internet
or now making claims about hey it
doesn't really fit there I didn't
realize how much you hate this show this
Punchy comes across the deer and similar
to the game she fails to down it we have
a moment mirroring the sniper scene from
episode 6 and I did appreciate how they
built off the back of that yeah David
and James come across it and he does the
typical religious preacher strategy okay
all I ask is 10 seconds of your time I
just I won't say it twice let's see how
these scenes play alongside those in the
game
My Favorites
[Music]
that's what they were missing from the
episode the bone arrow who's there
now
hello
we just want to talk any sudden moves
and I put one right between your eyes
and he shot him moves I put them right
between your eyes do you know for Buddy
Boy ditto for Buddy Boy over there
what do you want
name's David
this here's my friend James
we're from a larger group women children
and we're all very very hungry
from a larger group
women children
they're all very very hungry
so am I
women and children all very hungry too
well even so
you can't drag this back on your own
huh
maybe we could
trade you for some of that meat there
what do you need
you're not asking for charity we we can
trade you for some of the deer we have
what do you need we have medicine
weapons
ammo clothes medicine
you have any antibiotics
like for infections
we do
the camp
welcome to follow I'm not following you
anywhere
we do back in our village you're welcome
to follow us I'm not following you
anywhere change it
he comes back with what I need the deer
is all yours
buddy boy can go get it he comes back
you get half the deer anyone else shows
up you put one right between my eyes
that's right anyone else shows up
right between my eyes
that's right
two bottles of the penicillin in a
syringe make it fast
go on yeah he's questioning him already
we've got two bottles and a syringe
it's not code James do as I said
I'll take that rifle David looks so
creepy to get
now David is well aware of who Ellie is
at this point and as we later learn it
was his men that went to the university
either way they go into one of the Huts
which is similar to how they camped up
in the game here we learn a bit more
about David and discover that he was a
maths teacher who converted to become a
preacher after the world fell apart not
even gonna go down the rabbit hole with
avoiding that but we do learn that he
came from Pittsburgh the cusey there
fell in 2017 due to a war between the
fireflies in Federer which is something
that was sort of touched upon in the
game in the show Ali and Joe went to
Kansas City whereas in the source
material that was Pittsburgh where the
whole Henry and something happened you
arrived there to find it overrun by
Bandits and could piece together enough
things to learn about what happened
Pedra had been keeping rations for
themselves and starving people and when
they were ousted the bandits froze up in
their place people like David ended up
leaving and they run into the same
problem when it comes to food the
dialogue in the scene starts to
transform into how it plays out in the
game you know you really shouldn't be
out here
I don't like company you know you really
shouldn't be out here all on your own
from where I'm sitting you shouldn't be
at her on your own
I see
what's your name
why
fair enough
so what's your name
look I understand it's not easy to trust
a couple of strangers
it's hard to trust strangers I know but
I honestly mean you no harm
say we like a pretty good team
it's after we get lucky
oh you look how to run up sooner or
later look
lucky no no such thing as luck
you see I believe
and everything happens for a reason
no such thing as love no I I believe
everything happens for a reason this
winner
has been especially cruel
we didn't expect this winner to be so
cruel
nothing will grow
game's been hard to find because of the
fact that they really leaned into David
being a preacher his delivery sounds
like that like he sounds like he's
talking to his his sheep like even when
he's talking to Ellie it sounds like
he's preaching in a way like there's
that that delivery and Cadence in the
show itself whereas it doesn't sound
that way at all in the game what's a
preacher it's a thing that smart people
follow oh and that there's a select
group of people who don't follow oh okay
because
they don't recognize Who The Real Son of
God
I do agree with you and again because we
had not seen anything from David's
perspective before in the video game
again he's just a suspicious fellow who
after an action sequence now we've built
some trust and camaraderie between the
two of them you don't really have like
some basis of background of why he's
speaking the way he does but yes I agree
with you it plays a lot more into the
scene and makes a lot more sense with
given the background that we have of him
so uh what are you doing this Sunday do
you have a place I should go visit yeah
a synagogue maybe oh no no those are on
Saturdays
I think Friday night I'm not I'm not the
best you but I believe no we'll head up
the other Jews see when you're supposed
to go a few weeks back I am sent a group
of men out
nearby Town look for food
so I sent four of our people to a nearby
town to to scavenge what they could
only a few came back
and only three of them came back
you said that the others had been
slaughtered
I uh crazy man turns out he was murdered
by this crazy man
I get this he's a crazy man traveling
a little girl and get this
that crazy man
was traveling with a little girl
you see
everything happens for a reason you see
everything happens for a reason
a gun he's the one that killed Alec and
she she didn't kill anybody
lower the gun now give her the medicine
you know this won't be happy about this
did you bring the medicine out
yeah throw it to her David well the [__]
out of the way love you Ashley Johnson
won't survive long out there
[Music]
I can't protect you
you won't survive for long out there
I can protect you
oh thanks
[Music]
you know after that shot that they had
of of Troy Baker am I completely missing
this guy's career has he not done a lot
of live action works so mesmerizing in
every frame he has and like we didn't
even recognize him right away it took a
second for me to recognize him for sure
yeah you had to point out that I was
like oh yeah that is him I'm obviously
not that familiar with like the face of
Troy I've seen him of course but you had
to point him out for me to be like oh
yeah that's him but he's so captivating
in every frame he has here so it's not
some Nostalgia thing for Troy Baker that
I have when watching him there's so much
performance in his eyes alone yeah I'm
like what why is he only mainly known
for voice over work when he clearly is a
phenomenal like live action actor as
well his voice is synonymous with video
games he's legendary I mean anyone who's
played any of the video games that he's
voiced of you know that so I think that
is maybe cut into his live-action career
because I agree with you like he really
surprised me in this episode I was
watching I'm like freaking really good
why are you doing more live action it's
just the role of James yeah
I mean every time the camera's on him
he's really like I'm pulled in yeah for
sure I do miss in the game like how
Sinister the surrounding atmosphere is
with the lighting of how dark it is and
then you see how David just is evolving
into the monster with like the way the
fire and Shadow is casting a specific
kind of lighting over him it feels a
little bit more like something demonic
in a way I remember experiencing this
for the first time and my stomach
dropped with the turn this was a guy he
just bought side by side with and had
now inadvertently revealed yourself as
being one of the people that caused this
town so much torment now they've added
in a layer where the person Joe killed
being the father of the girl at the
steakhouse and they of course are
supposed to reflect Joe and Ellie we see
how the stories have changed too which
y'all being described as a crazy man
whereas we know from our side that
attack them in the game we we never saw
David and James's side after the
conversation but here we can see the
doubting him resurfaced once more as
David lets her go now we return back to
the house and again see things play out
similar to how they do in the game
Joel
I I just can't take how good the PS5
Graphics are it's insane
[Music]
here we go
yo where the [__] do I put this
such a good actress
[Music]
oh
thank you for cutting that up
you're gonna make it
[Music]
I love I love that moment so much
originally this was the moment that you
learned Joel was alive and he'd had a
large part of the game his Ali where he
had no idea what his fate was similar to
the game Ellie lies down with him and
whereas in that we could at the morning
to see David's forces coming in here we
cut to the town there's a lot of focus
given to the meat with people clearly
knowing what's going on so they keep it
to themselves because the truth's too
difficult sweet it's hard venison but
whether that's actually true or not is
another thing entirely James does talk
about supplies earlier in the episode
but we know from their interactions that
they use code with each other they could
all be lying to themselves keeping their
mind off it and it can mirror the
predatory behavior with David but let me
know what you think below at this point
David and James arrived with the deer
and you could say that like David James
because they saved
bit of an English joke there and David
admits that they've found who killed
alecially slapping his daughter when she
suggests killing them shows just how
abusive that he is and he tells the girl
that he's her father the now entire town
sits in silence and allows it to happen
I think it very much shows the grip that
he has over everyone when things come
out about figures like this you'll often
hear about how many people were aware of
what was going on but they turned a
blind eye to it it's very much the idea
that you don't have to deal with
something if you ignorant to it and no
matter how horrific it is you can
reassure yourself that everything is
okay the reason I question this venison
is because this could very much be
carried over to the food too and we get
a lot of focus on the town's people
wolfing it down these are happy to just
talk into their food have a warm meal
and be quiet because speaking UPS better
than starving I would then jump back to
Ellie and see as Joe looks slightly
better was it the dad that they they
don't clarify do that they feel like
clarifying but I mean the body's what
turn to bones and I I don't know how
long there is that line in there earlier
in the episode when he says that we we
have to wait to bury your dad yeah so I
gotta Matt I I have to imagine that's
what it is which is poetic and
disgusting at the same time I think it's
all awesome
next time I come over we're gonna eat
someone
dude this is YouTube they specifically
say cannibalism is demons
we won't do that great
she injects him once more and we get a
slight differentiation from the game
mazeli gets to go outside whereas in the
game she spotted people coming in from
the basement we get a great scene with
David and James with the former clearly
wanting to take care even though it will
only cause problems with people back in
their Community David wants to spare her
because he has ulterior motives whereas
James sees it as being God's will that
they should leave her to die this very
much reflects Kathleen from earlier in
the season who believed it was Sam's
Fate To Die instead of getting the
leukemia medicine either way in both
versions Ali decides to head out and
draw them away with us getting a big
action scene Ellie leaves Joe with a
knife and this is what he later uses to
interrogate the people with in the game
Ellie took her horse and Road through
the streets as the hunter slept out to
grab her and eventually the horse was
shot and she fell down a Cliffside she
then navigated the surroundings and got
into a hotel which is where she tried to
escape Yoshi stealthily took out hunters
and eventually was grabbed by David
which is when she was transported at the
camp yeah they keep the sort of energy
the same but shorten things a bit with a
writing out and the horse getting shot
by James David demands that Ellie has
taken and alive and I did find it
interesting how he mirrors Kathleen a
need for Revenge led to him making dumb
decisions and David's need to have Ali
leads to him doing the same thing he
stops Sally from being shot and even
carries her away similar to how giol
carried Sarah at the start of the Season
yeah
is pretty much a reverse Joel and he's
arguably the most dangerous person we
encounter in the whole show now it's uh
that's outside of one of your characters
but moving on I'm in the game one
Sally's captured we then switch
perspectives to see Joe like what we get
here when he first took control you're
stumbling in about and a little boy's
for where which it is like how he
appears here too attention from the
scene comes from the fact that Joel is
almost out of it but he manages to get
the upper hand and take down David's men
now the death scene here is terrifying
with a lot of the struggles feeling like
they're ripped right out of the game the
facial expressions especially are
something that I always spin the camera
around to see and I get I guess we've
discovered that I'm a bit of a
psychopath but please subscribe and from
here we get the interrogation scene I
was so happy seeing this playing out as
I was thinking that the scene with
graham green was gonna be the show's
version of it might have spoiled a scene
for you if you watched our breakdown for
that episode but I genuinely thought
that's how they were going to play it
the Disney the Disney interrogation was
how I thought they were are gonna play
this scene now because they're so
similar you might be asking why have
they done something that's basically the
same scene as that well it's for a good
reason as yeah we're seeing the true
side of gel when Ellie's not around in
the cabin we knew nothing was gonna
happen as did the couple because there
was a little girl here they were likely
aware Joel wouldn't do anything which is
why they ended up laughing yeah though
giola is free to do what he wants and
he'll do whatever he wants to get Ali
back now let's play the scenes from the
game let's show you how Stuff lines up
so much leave him alone
please I don't know any girl is she
alive what girl I don't know no girl
oh Jesus
[__] Focus right here right here
not popping goddamn knee off you focused
wrap up your [__] kneecap off oh he's
so good it's a girl
she's alive
it's too long
where
[Applause]
in the town ah the town what town
Silver Lake
now you're gonna mark it on the map
you're gonna point to where we are and
where your Resort is and it better be
the same exact spot your buddy points to
and it better be the exact same spot
your buddy points to Market
it's right there you can verify it go
ask him go ask him he'll tell you I'm
not lying I ain't telling you [__]
okay no I believe him no
I love the smile on Joel's face it's all
right
I believe it you also get a follow-up
from this with Ellie and a moment that
builds upon the original
I know you're hungry
been out for quite some time
although in the game she does eat it
dear dear what it's worth this is just
dear meat I swear it's just the deer
meat
you're a [__] animal
you're gonna chop me up into little
pieces so now what
you're gonna chop me up into tiny pieces
I'd rather not
please just tell me your name please
tell me your name
you're so full of [__]
if you want to judge me judge you
[Music]
I quit the judgment
considering you and your friend killed
how many men the only way I'm going to
be able to convince the others
around
you have heart
you're loyal
and you're special
you're smart
loyal
oh
in the life we could build
okay
[Music]
oh [__] you stupid little girl
yeah
what am I supposed to tell the others
now
you'd see when I go tell the others now
oh I love it Ellie
what Ally
what
tell them that
Ellie is the little girl
tell them that Ellie is a little girl
who broke her [__] finger I broke
your [__] finger
how did you put it huh
tiny pieces
how did you put it
tiny little pieces Ellie realizing that
cannonballs is so chilling because they
mistake and it was a mistake getting
Ellie caged like this this picturesque
Last Resort on the world has turned into
something where people have turned to
cannibalism as a last resort and what
did the frustrated cannibal do
David recognizes the violent Hall with
an alley and he even talks about how
cordyceps showed him the truth of the
world it feeds and protects his children
and he thinks that it actually loves I
realize at this point that the religion
things are charad and that he lets
others believe it because it brings them
Comfort however it also brings people
closer to him and though he won't admit
it it allows him to be propped up and
the cordyceps loving is something that
the show's creditors have talked about
on the podcast and even said that they
had the kiss with Tess to hammer harm
this idea love is a lace throughout
every aspect of the show and we've seen
both the positives and negatives of it
you have people like Bill and Frank and
the couplin episode 6 but then you have
people like Kathleen and geol who it
just causes pain for David has a sick
and twisted kind of love and when he's
assaulting Ellie later on he creepily
says don't be afraid that there's no
fear in love now the cordyceps are very
much made him believe that his sick and
twisted be of the world is the right one
and it's a chilling way to portray the
character although his plan with Ali
fails it's likely that he would have got
her into the camp had things not gonna
lie everyone was just silent about him I
doubt they would have spoken up and thus
he probably could have got her as one of
the members taking out chill would have
helped him because he was the only
person defending him and a dahlia the
villagers would have been like yeah
Ellie's my friend especially after this
stuff for the University thus early
would have been alone and what people
tend to do in abusive relationships is
that they get people away from their
friends and family thus they have no one
to fall back on and with his safety gun
they can fully manipulate the person and
control every aspect of their life the
only aspect you get in the game of
seeing David as the leader of them is
the fact that he's out there on the hunt
with them and here you get a lot more of
the actual psychological manipulation
and how people respond to him back at
their village where you can see this guy
knows how to use the power of God to
make himself it's like in a way he views
himself as a God in this situation you
know he even has a line in there I think
at some point about you know they'll do
whatever I want I want them to do you
know he he views it like by being the
messenger for God he views himself as
the actual God in this situation I
thought in the game he was written so
freaking well and obviously Noah North
did a fantastic job right but I kept
thinking in the game like why are they
listening to him why are they following
him because we obviously we're not
getting to see the perspective from
their side actually watching it from
here in the way it's expanded upon this
episode I'm like okay now I understand
why they are following David why they
fear for David the manipulation he
invokes on them how he just views them
as His sheep and he's the shepherd and
all them like this makes so much more
sense now it gives more context to the
game even even though you don't have
that stuff in the game it just gives
context and that's the kind of stuff
that I love like when you do adaptations
of video games or whatever and you give
that that other stuff that was not uh
expanded upon and it just like adds gaps
there now back with Joe we see as the
storm rolls in and he makes his way to
Salt Lake this is a similar thing to the
game and at this point you're able to
mask your movements by using the
environment now inside a Hut there he
discovers belongings and bodies hanging
up which is similar to what happens when
you enter one in the game yeah he's
backpack which is ripped right out of it
too and he realizes just how much
trouble she's in the episode in general
it reminded me a lot of the movie the
road and which characters also come
across cannibals in that also it's
important to bear in mind that James is
comfortable doing this with the chopping
board probably because he's helped David
kill people like this before in the game
he even refers to Alias David's new pad
showing how he views her and we then get
at least Escape in another scene that's
ripped right out of the game wakey wakey
I was so smart
I wore you
[Music]
had your chance
I'm excited really
so are you
really
roll on my sleeve look at it
right there it's always
look at it I'll play along I'll play
along
what'd you say what did you say
I love the reactions everything happens
for a reason right
what the hell is that now she would have
turned by now this isn't real she would
have turned by now it can't be real
looks pretty [__] real to me
[Music]
I might be asking whether Ellie buying
someone can actually infect them and
there's a bit in the second game that
clears this up I'll talk about that in
the super spoiler section section but we
do kind of know the answer to it either
way they cut the sections down here and
compress the scene so that Ellie goes
immediately into the restaurant in the
game he made your way through the town
and jumped back and forth between Joel
and Ellie I think it's actually smarter
to handle it like this and we see Ellie
getting log which ends up setting the
place on fire in the game as he went to
escape David grabbed you and eventually
this knocked over a lamp which then
started the Blaze and several lines in
the game are pulled directly across here
no way out Ellie
the doors are locked and I have the keys
nowhere to go
you want out
let's come get these Keys now Ali
burning down this quote-unquote church
also symbolically shows how she's
burning down the facade of everything
David spelled the pair battle it out
with one another and the struggle ends
up being exactly like how it is in the
game
foreign
[Music]
it's me it's me
yeah I like breaking the batter it's
like bringing Darkness into the light
[Music]
it's okay baby girl look at you
during David's death we keep the focus
on Ellie and it shows how much our kill
she's giving to this wicked and evil man
shall Comforts her and we get a really
important line dropped here where he
calls her baby girl this is the same
nickname that he gave to Sarah and at
this point he's all in on this being his
daughter the pair woke off together with
his arm around you're my daughter only
we're in episode two after Tessa's death
Jill stormed away leaving Ali Raz here
we see them closer than they've ever
been the pair have bonded over
everything and whereas she once was just
cargo here he's putting a card around
here to let her know everything's okay
wait that was this imagery that's often
used in the show and game and it stages
the characters are going on the next
part of their Journey now before we get
into the spoiler section I'll give my
review and I thought this episode was
really solid with some great
performances in it Scott Shepard brought
a lot to David at that point he was even
creepier than Nolan North in the game
things are are a lot more implied but
there were some extra lines of dialogue
that they added which really freaked me
out now it was also really nice seeing
Troy Baker too and he gave a lot away
from just minor facial expressions Kyle
looked completely beaten up at points
and his Meek performance made me think
that he very much represented the town's
citizens who refused to confront David I
think this episode worked really well as
an evolution of Ellie as well and it's
no coincidence that this is the chapter
in the game where you first take control
of her like that section this is very
much about her having to fight to
survive without help from others so far
she's relied on people like Federer
Riley Marlene Joel Tess and Henry and
Sam well this is her showing that when
she's cornered she can handle things
that come her way you also see that the
character is realizing that this world
isn't as fun as its cracked up to be
going back to the opening in episode 3
we've seen how she thought wielding a
gun with something cool and also
exciting here though we have his
smashing David's head like it's a like
button and we see the Relentless anger
that she carries a huge change in
Dynamic and her growth is a character
now as for what I didn't like you
already know what I'm gonna say and I
think the show has continued to under
use the infected which has taken away
from some of the most memorable scenes
of the game I think if we had something
with David where they had to fight some
of them it would have made that turn as
impactful as it is in the game and with
the episode just being 45 minutes long I
think we could have easily have gotten
another 10 or even five minutes where we
had something like that play out I'm
guessing that they pulled back on shiny
in fact it is much because of the budget
but every week it seems like there's a
major moment involving them which is
left on The Cutting Room floor minor
nitpick and yeah obviously the game's
there if you want to see more of them
but I did kind of want an action scene
like that with Ellie so we could see
what she was capable of against humans
and also the infected and that takes us
into the Super spoiler section and for
the next part of the video I want to go
over some of the Easter eggs that will
probably give the the game away if you
don't want things spoiled then thanks
for watching thanks a lot mate again for
wasting 40 minutes of your life and I
hope to see you back for the finale next
week now the first thing I want to talk
about is the interrogation technique in
part two aliors ends up using this and
we of course needed to see her actually
see it for herself in order to explain
how she knows this you also discover
that Silver Lake is oh yeah
I wonder if this line was thrown to show
how Resorts have changed across the
country as part 2 ends with Ellie going
to a resort on the hunt for Abby this
was controlled by slavers and you can
see how these holiday locations have
been Twisted in this new world and
lastly is Ellie buying David was he
infected was he not we don't fully know
however Ellie does end up kissing Dino
in the second game and at one point she
also bites Abby when she's buying her in
the theater as we know Abby doesn't get
infected and thus I don't think that
Ellie's bite actually could infect
people infection seems to have stopped
at her um and not made its way to
herself cyber glands and this I don't
think she passes it on so I don't think
Ellie actually infected David and either
she didn't know or she used it as a
weapon rather see she's been told to
hide it from people but she pulls her
down this moment to further slow down
confusion yeah this throws James off a
bit and it adds upon what he was
experiencing before allowing Ali to
escape anyway that wraps up the video
and huge thank you for sticking with me
until the end wow are you gonna say he
didn't miss one like the drink I'm
surprising to talk at all about how Joel
the person the reason they want revenge
against trolls for killing the someone
who's a father oh yes yes and then
leaving a little girl behind who who
declares She Wants Revenge well he
didn't go in the time machine and watch
her reaction and to know so it was like
my main takeaway with the change was
like wow that's a massive foreshadow
yeah I mean that's what that's what he's
got us for I need to message him like
why are you dropping the ball here or
Paul Paul with the drop balls but if if
you noticed on not only the reaction but
here too I don't mind those other action
sequences where like where Ellie was
fending off and just gotta keep
defending yourself
no I'm just saying a lot of people think
but I'm going to keep saying the point
I'm making is like I don't mind you
getting rid of certain things yeah thank
you I don't mind you getting rid of
certain action it's storytelling action
sequences that I like to be kept it's
all filler
um thank you so yeah it's all Phil or
Andrew yeah the show is perfect they
never make a miscalculation nothing is
per it's every episode 10 out of 10 and
you're a bigot if you say otherwise
uh yeah specifically a bigot you're a
Last of Us hater you're a bigot I love
that that's so funny
anyway Andrew guys they should subscribe
to Paul and we should also do it
Andrew pick any name here go back down
okay we gotta go with David David Gandy
oh that is perfect
David is actually quite a religious
person in real life too so this is this
is a wonderful perfect choice for this
David uh yeah David sometimes performs
music uh at his church as well he's a
guitarist he's a man of God God-fearing
individual and now David I think it's
about time you take over that church of
yours right now what they need is a
solid preacher they need you to rise to
the ranks I know that sometimes when we
talk to you can sound a little bit meek
and you got this really soft-spoken
voice but that's so you can lure people
in make you seem trustworthy and like oh
he's so nice but David come on man now
is your time to take control of the
people at your church you can get them
to do whatever you want Mr Gandy why are
you wasting your time
just being a shepherd and nope wrong
word one of the sheep when you could be
the Shepherd come on dude David
what is America without taking advantage
of other people get involved get in the
action man it's all about manipulation
all about manipulation dude all about
manipulation now I gotta clarify for
YouTube when I'm being serious or
sarcastic I'm being a hundred percent
serious right now it is
Arizona's boring
do something interesting in Arizona
start a new cult
I'm sorry David
praise be to God keep your faith thank
you for being a patron of ours for so
long Anthony you want to say David thank
you David I will visit you in church
sometimes if uh my Rabbi says it's okay
oh God
I can't wait to eat you
with or without the yamaka on oh
with okay perfect with the Yamaha I've
always said in my head if I want to get
eaten it's with Miami con so I
appreciate you at least I just ordered
five yamakas off Amazon
it's a weird video
[Music]